And anything you could do in
here would be awesome.
I can't believe I can
afford an interior designer.
This is all very new
for me.
Well, the space
is fabulous.
Yeah?
Yeah.
In here, I'm thinking
we do
a classic
hand-woven Belgian rug
and then rich fabrics,
sconces, tote linens.
Sconces--
Oh, my God.
Yeah, we could even
do a brushed
cotton twill
window treatment.
Very elegant.
This place needs to feel
like your sanctuary.
Totally.
This all sounds
great.
Okay-- So we've got
the entry,
the living room
and the bedroom
and what are we thinking
for the (bleep)?
Excuse me?
Because for the (bleep),
we could continue the sort
of timeless ambience
of the living room
or try something new.
Maybe go for a more regal
feel in the (bleep).
The bathroom
is fine as is.
The (bleep) is
fine?
That room's all set.
I'm sorry,
I missed that-- That room?
Are we talking living room,
bedroom or (bleep)?
The last one-- Let's
move on.
Oh, yeah, yeah,
yeah.
We can- we can get
back to it.
Okay, thanks.
Can I ask
you something crazy?
Mm-hmm.
Would you ever do a suede
chaise lounge?
Oh, that
sounds really expensive.
I've got news for you--
It's not...
and you
can dump the savings
straight into your new
fudge depot.
You know,
your turd bank.
I'd rather not.
Look, a beautiful
corn silo is gonna be
a great investment.
Remember, this is
the room where you spend
80% of your day.
That doesn't seem accurate.
Close your eyes.
Hey-- Close them.
Imagine coming home.
You plop down on your gorgeous
porcelain dook throne,
drop a ton of heat
and then slip into
the tub
to clean your
filthy balloon knot.
That actually does sound
kind of perfect.
Right?
You know what--
Let's do it.
Yeah, I'm
completely on board.
Will you just excuse me
one minute?
I just have
to pee real fast.
Pee?
(gagging)
I'll still take it.
Okay.